pinky made room for me
what are you doing i'm in here oh my
goodness
give me take a hit let's take a look
here let me watch you we gotta go
are you ready are you ready are you
ready are you ready
are you ready are you ready let's go
don't be in there messing up my restroom
i don't want to hear it mom winter is
messing up my restroom
don't mess it
[Music]
you want to up for lab values
[Music]
that means we need to go over them
i'll call you okay all right sounds good
it's been a few months
since we've been back from the dominican
republic and
now that we're back to normal life at
home pedro and i are just
trying not to get swept up in family
drama
and focus on day-to-day life
together yeah
my focus right now is school and passing
my exams
graduation is a few weeks away and i am
so
done it's time this is the start of a
new
chapter because in our lives let me
let me explain because chandalfin is
cool we can buy a house
i want to start a school and i want to
spend all my life work in the warehouse
it's like a big dream american dream
pinky in america you need to
think big tell your family they have to
think small because they're on a small
island so stop asking for money
so we can live big
[Music]
you